you've smoked with Snoop yeah many times
well how do you guys how do you guys
come to smoke together how does Snoop
what do you mean when you say you enjoy
smoking with Seth are there people who
can bum you out yeah because they talk
too [ __ ] much they just get in
the way but Seth enjoys the moment he's
creative it's my [ __ ] knows how to
make a joint that looks like a cross yes
it's true oh you shown us that yeah he's
a bad [ __ ] damn when he pulled
that cross out I was like God ever come
about where you guys would say hey we
had such a nice experience being with
one another and enjoying weed let's get
together and specifically just smoke
weed or is it just say you're somewhere
socially is that how it happens you find
this JD smoking for the first time I
said you gotta listen these guys are
heavyweights this is like you know these
guys know how to do we they really do
and you got to be careful I told them
and tell me if this is right maybe three
hits I'd start with one more right I say
half of one yeah exactly two guys -
Betty [ __ ] come up and get way
hey my dream is to smoke with you
[Laughter]